soir jean luc addor merci d'être avec
nous en direct de berne
alors pourquoi votre pays at-il donc
choisi de commander ce fameux f 35
on le rappelle à la somme est coquette 4
6 milliard et 1,8 milliard d'euros pour
la défense seul patriotes alors qu'al
c'est le rafale ou l'eurofighter était
encore favori pour remporter la mise
concept que les américains ont fait
carton plein parce qu'on avait en fait
un processus d'acquisition complet pour
deux systèmes donc un nouvel avion de
combat et une défense se lève à longue
portée et les américains l'ont emporté
des deux côtés ce qui me frappe
personnellement c'est que le conseil
fédéral présente ce choix comme un choix
purement techniques et financiers alors
que tout le monde sait que s'agissant
particulièrement de deux systèmes qui
sont faits pour la pour la défense gagne
1 à l'évidence une composante politique
que ce soit géopolitique à des
composantes de politique intérieure
aussi dont on peut pas faire dont on ne
peut pas faire l'économie
quelles sont ses composantes justement
ces faits qui nous intrigue un peu je
pense que avec chacun des pays
constructeurs ont la suisse à des
contentieux multi d'un ordre ou d'un
autre avec l'ensemble donc c'était
l'occasion peut-être de d'essayer de
régler partiellement ces contentieux
peut et on voit que on a un contentieux
peut-être qu'il est apparue plus
récemment avec avec l'union européenne
et je pensais personnellement que la
suisse avait l'occasion ont choisi sans
un système européen de de contribuer à
régler ces contentieux
c'est un petit peu une gifle non pas à
l'égard de l'union européenne tension
pardonnez-moi mais qu'elle compte sur
vous faites référence précisément vous
savez avec les états unis on est des
contentieux fiscaux bancaire et c'est la
même chose la même chose avec la france
avec l'allemagne on a aussi différents
contentieux avec l'aéroport de zurich
etc
et puis on a une occasion de
collaboration et la question c'est à
partir du moment ce qui ce qui était à
première vue le cas à partir du moment
où on avait affaire à quatre avions qui
tous les quatre ans qui sait le caïd et
sa décharge prévu par les par les
militaires et bien pour moins ce qu'ils
devaient faire la différence
c'était quand même aussi des éléments
politiques de politique data de de
géopolitique est la question qui se
posait c'était de savoir avec quel pays
auquel groupe de pays la suisse
c'est en ce moment où pour ces
prochaines années a le plus intérêt à à
collaborer et je pense que c'était une
question d' union européenne à
strictement parler on c'est une gifle à
l'égard d' de d'état européens
et ça je pense que c'est une occasion
ratée de collaboration avec des pays qui
sont proches de la suisse et ont donné
un autre signal qui est celui la
collaboration avec pour ces systèmes
très très important avec finalement un
seul partenaire
quand même beaucoup plus lointain qui
sont les états unis c'est ce qui retient
l'attention plutôt choisir un lointain
que un proche vous avez dit c'est un
signal il faut dire que joe biden s'est
rendu à genève le 16 juin dernier
peut-être que ça a joué en tout cas la
suisse ne risque-t-elle pas de perdre le
tra lité en dépendons vous l'avez l'ire
d'un programme 100% américain en tout
cas nous mettons pour ce programme n'a
donc à deux volets encore une fois
l'avion et la défense sol-air la suisse
la suisse a choisi de mettre ses oeufs
dans le même panier
je suis pas sûr que c'est comme ça qu'on
va le mieux assurer notre notre
indépendance et est surtout une
collaboration nécessaire avec avec des
pays voisins qui qui nous sont quand
même très proche on a des contentieux
bien sûr mais mais nous sommes très
proches et c'était on avait l'occasion
de contribuer à les régler je pense que
c'est une occasion ratée alors la gauche
crie ça ne l'entend pas de cette oreille
et elle souhaite même organisé une
votation pour faire annuler cet accord
est ce qu elle a des chances d'aboutir
vous savez on a on a espéré on a voté au
suisse en septembre de l'année dernière
sur le principe de la modernisation de
nos forces aériennes et on a espéré
faire l'économie d'un débat populaire
sur le choix du modèle et on est en
train de s'apercevoir que c'était une
illusion que qu'on ne va pas y couper si
j'ose dire à à ce débat populaire et je
pense que si on considère qu'en
septembre de l'année dernière ça s'est
joué à 8000 voix mais je pense que ce
sera un débat très dangereux et je
parlais de géopolitique à des questions
de politique intérieure c'est celle dans
laquelle vous venez de
faire allusion je pense que le groupe
pour une suisse sans armée la gauche les
verts tendent un piège au conseil
fédéral
est-ce que je crains c'est que le
conseil fédéral se soit précipité droit
dans le piège qu'on lui tendait avec
risque que fille de remettre en cause
finalement cette acquisition nécessaires
pour la sécurité de notre pays
merci beaucoup jean luc addor d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france